all of the the roles I've done if they
were over like would you want to revisit
there's not one role I've done where I'm
like I never want to play that again you
know what I mean not one not one and I
think the I've always had this lipus
test and it served me well when I take
on a roll I always think it's myself am
I gonna be excited on my ride to work
even the Vampire movie yeah you do it in
a heartbeat in a heartbeat I mean I'm
probably too old to play now cuz like
vampires don't age but uh you can age if
you want to can you no vampire you don't
drink enough blood and you get older and
then you drink blood no I think I they
can change the [__] around they could I
think they could I think you look good I
thank you man it's all in the eyes